it plays off of the similar kind of
character types that you always see on
Netflix that you always see in the TV
commercials and TV shows now the the the
the white guy was a loser the white
woman was just a racist hateful
individual where literally the movie
started with her saying how she hates
everybody and the white guy was a cuck
or something yeah he's like a he's like
a beta totally scared pathetic and
running and crying and I'm like oh yeah
yeah you know just the average kind of
bull crap that you usually see in enter
entertainment now which literally just
plays on your subconscious and uh tries
to install messages in there that are uh
dehum and divisive especially racially
uh so I watched half of the movie there
was also a very interesting scene
surrounding Teslas so um I still haven't
watched all of it um I don't like it cuz
I already see a lot of the kind of
subliminal messaging in there that's
like okay this is pandering to the woke
ESG score message that comes from a lot
of these you